if one is losing you could literally
reset the game by being a little [ __ ] I
would never do that
because I'm on this person and now we're
never lying I think you would probably
do that well you reset this one yes
promise no I'm playing half me to here
at the second coming with the cries of
hazards game they just read in 30
seconds and you can say that I offer
tours that you also you can eat curry
enjoy so let's start with the most
difficult one oh [ __ ] it why not
Wow why do we should know how to do this
what is this play your battle thing can
we fight or each other oh no I don't
want to fight you how do we could battle
each other to activate hostile mode you
can battle each other on other teams
oh okay laters are later if we yeah I'm
Way more cat way than you cry on display
meta what okay so so good I think you
should be this the blue one no I don't
be that blondie I like it it looks like
I'm going to a baseball game in the rain
hey how do I choose to 500k Oh 100 goal
I get it you need to handicap you what
are you doing on my side oh god I'm a
diet I die right away
no that's possible okay okay the first
one I don't know are you doing good I
know I can get it
alright I'm actually doing really well
oh you [ __ ] I was thing really bad
[ __ ] you're welcome we are so not gonna
battle and tell them like this don't
come near me
oh thank you
good your anymore you have to reset it
focus on resetting I don't even have an
axe come on you're gonna fight without a
weapon yes I mean when I don't have a
weapon
yes you [ __ ] absolutely how dare you
you're welcome
I keep just fighting seashells and like
bones lay [ __ ] I need some good stuff
give me good oh god damn it that is way
too good for me
oh I got my ass whipped yeah by an
ostrich
really yep I'm sorry yeah [ __ ] I'll be
I'll reset it wait I have it yes I'm not
near it oh you're on these already Jesus
Christ crap yeah pretty much
don't hit my people all right going in
bye what do you do hey you have to get
the next one it's fine yeah because
you've leveled off like a little [ __ ] I
don't need it cuz a [ __ ] one true
hero I'm not gonna kick this part
anyways I no one's gonna know about it
[ __ ] yeah damn at the one time I was
supposed to battle each other and you
just [ __ ] power leveled you know our
as well it wouldn't work yeah and you
never did it I did I was all red and
stuff nobody never did him I did it yet
a rainbow shields oh shut up I did okay
now now let's fight each other right
away we're away from each other
Shh don't fight it it's inevitable
you're not here what do you know about
that you're not okay I'm coming towards
you I'm over here now hi fight me I'm
battling these things you can't join me
and kill me
I just died huh okay that it's fine
don't worry about it I got that again
really oh my god and I'm gonna die again
yeah you have to get it you have to get
it you have to get it I'm not we have to
tell
I didn't have anything you did that I
did not perfect I was getting Quebec
help me oh sure
monsters sure okay so later all right
come on I can't believe you did that
quit the game too geez right oh you're
already leveling up a bit no no no no
are you fighting over there you want to
fight you use your fighting over there
right now
you want to fight over that oh no I
joined you damn it see this is what
happens what happens what what what is
it the thing that happens No exactly
reset it I resented it - all right
communication is key cry you know he
said I want to tell you [ __ ] exactly we
can totally toll each other like if it
goes if one is losing you could
literally reset the game by being a
little [ __ ] I would never do that
because I'm on this person and now we're
nowhere lying I think you would probably
do that
will you reset this one yes promise no
that's the meanest thing anyone has ever
done to me I feel so betrayed right now
that's good are you okay I'm not even
gonna ask yeah just gonna do it again
yeah I'm just like you should cuz I'm an
honest person I don't [ __ ] around we're
gonna do it I just [ __ ] did it i I I
was gonna do it but I miss died right
after
oh yeah but sword no please I don't
battle anymore human side battle Wolf's
OGC makes things explode cry stop it
come back
calm down you dead why don't I have a
battle-axe answer you have to do this
you have to purchase them I don't pray
you think I buy purchase the deal see do
you know how expensive it it's I died
you're gonna have to reset it I had to I
have to buy Korean axis and skirts with
boobs on it yeah yeah I'm good
you keep buying rainbow shields yeah
pride man I got a rep the LGBT community
bro okay good good yeah I'm dead again
oh Jesus
okay you're gonna have to get this one
uh I don't have enough I don't know I
swear to god I'll have enough I swear to
god her and have enough say okay okay
alright alright god I got it yeah guys
okay we've yet to fight each other yeah
well that's because you're a little
[ __ ] and no one dare to find me one
United States think of it okay so you're
gonna have to get this money I I got it
actually I'm from the ostriches yeah you
wife this is way harder than the other
ones yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah shut up
it is alright what are they one night
what was their werewolf and I fought
monkeys and why don't I am yeah I'm
gonna get this one I'm gonna be good to
both of us and get this one why I'm not
getting it I promise
I know I'm getting it okay okay I got it
yeah stream thank you so much I promise
I will get the next one yeah yeah you
sure yeah I don't mind positive not
allowing though conniving wills No
yep yoke okay that's fair yeah how did
you can you like fight them cuz
sometimes I like want to fight them but
they don't want to find me and I'm lying
without well I'm currently naked so I
have no idea whoa I literally bought
underwear and I have no armor on that
sounds like a regular Tuesday exactly
what am i holding a helicopter pad yep
you jealous yes no why are you such a
low-level
what happened Kai because my level was
halved Oh does that randomly that little
little meanie I know right
I can't trust these I'm gonna get it oh
okay I'm good fight em fight em you want
to fight me now because I'm dying I
can't I am and you're naked
what if Ken doing I don't think I think
we're actually together and we didn't
just make it more difficult for us I
just you know what [ __ ] I'm gonna go
fight the bus you can't beat the boss I
totally take the bus you know try me
you're 52 now what the hell where I am I
have to kill the boss no that's ok I'm
here wait for the bus
[ __ ] you yeah I don't need you well you
have to get the time yeah I thought for
sure you would play me in like don't you
are in a diaper what do you think it's a
true hero the [ __ ] guy who doesn't
need armor to be a [ __ ] man ok is I
tapped it you have a freaking lightsaber
yeah I do I'm naked [ __ ] head with a
rainbow GBT
alright that was a good one I think we
can edit by their right every day